the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show the supreme
court is once again
starting to nibble a little bit at maybe
going after
gay marriage which we all thought was
completely settled in a closed book
since the 2015 supreme court decision
two supreme court justices mounted a
fresh attack this week on that ruling
from 2015.
um and uh we are now going to have to
see
because the court turn remember that
kentucky county clerk kim davis
who very famously and defiantly turned
away gay couples looking to get marriage
certificates
the court turned away in appeal by kim
davis
of a lower court ruling that let the
lawsuits
accusing her of violating the
constitutional rights of the couple's
proceed
the couple the court turned away that
appeal
and in the opinion that went along with
that justice clarence thomas and justice
samuel alito
wrote that the same-sex marriage ruling
continues to have
ruinous consequences for religious
liberty
and justice clarence thomas wrote davis
may have been one of the first
victims of this court's cavalier
treatment of religion
in its obergefell oh berg i don't
actually know how that's pronounced i
say obergefell
uh decision but she will not be the last
so thomas and alito agreed
on technical grounds to reject
the davis appeal but they still had to
put in there
in the decision that the decision
did leave a lot of people with religious
objections to gay marriage in a
difficult position
and a lot of people pat are looking at
this and seeing it as a signal
that were a case to be brought on
different grounds
they may be sympathetic to it renewing
the importance
of this upcoming supreme court
nomination of amy coney barrett
that's right because you already have
clarence thomas and samuel alito against
the gay marriage decision of 2015
so if you add to that gorsuch and
kavanaugh
and potentially amy coney barrett then
you have enough votes to overturn it and
it's only been five years
i mean if there was this precedent going
back a hundred years then maybe the
supreme court would be wary about
overturning it but five years they just
don't care about
uh republicans talk about these things
like precedent and
literal interpretations of the
constitution only when it's beneficial
to them and then
you know they backtrack when it's not so
this is definitely going to be on the
table if they get this
supreme court appointment through and it
should be a warning signal to
uh people in the lgbt community right i
mean like many people i think
who are gay lesbian bisexual now think
that this is just a settled issue
that gay marriage is going to remain the
law of the land going forward and it's
just you know baked in it's a permanent
thing so
maybe they're at liberty to vote for a
republican if they want tax cuts or
whatever
their reason may be you just know that
that comes with a risk right i mean they
could decide to overturn gay marriage
and
maybe that wouldn't be a problem here in
massachusetts or in california or in
some of the more liberal states but in
conservative places it certainly would
be
and and more likely than overturning it
i actually think that it is
insanely unlikely that gay marriage is
overturned
i think the more ominous and and
possibly
hidden uh uh outcome of a more
conservative supreme court
would be that exemptions start to be
added added added on religious grounds
to discriminate against lgbt individuals
i think that that
you know overturning gay marriage i
think would be very difficult and it
wouldn't be the first thing that happens
but you could
see the door opened for a court to say
you know based on this person's
individual objection based on that
person's individual objection they must
be allowed
to do x y z which would be
discriminatory actions
and then of course you're going to have
kim davises everywhere yeah you know
there's plenty of places in the south
more conservative parts of the country
where you're not probably going to be
able to find a clerk who will approve
your marriage license sure and despite
the fact that these people are operating
in official
government roles and they should just be
doing their job right i mean just
going along with the law they're going
to have this excuse of oh well i'm a
christian therefore i don't believe in
your marriage therefore
i'm going to just bypass my duties
altogether and not allow you to get
married and that can definitely happen i
mean
you'll probably see that if this takes
place so there's the abortion issue
there's the gay marriage issue
affordable care act like so many so many
different things hinge on whether or not
trump gets this last appointment and
also you know it's often not mentioned
when we talk about
the supreme court in addition to all of
the known issues you're talking about
there are unknown issues that will come
before the court remember we're talking
about lifetime appointments and many of
these justices could be on the courts
for decades to come
we don't know what key decision in 12
years
donald trump's selections to the court
will make trump may be dead
and he will still be having an effect
yeah let's say that joe biden gets
elected president
and his first act in office is to pass
some major
i don't know infrastructure package or
whatever and it's a historic deal it
takes like a year
but they jam it through congress and
they have the president sign it
oh well then it turns out three years
later the supreme court overturns it oh
well
all that time was wasted that could
definitely be the reality that we're
facing
there is a bombshell report which says
that former attorney general jeff
sessions you all remember him right
and deputy attorney general rod
rosenstein were
aggressively in favor of separating
migrant families at the u.s mexico
border
this draft report which is from the
justice department inspector general
says that this wasn't just you know the
ag and the deputy ag
were going along with it they were going
to allow it to go forward
the report says that they were a driving
force
behind donald trump's policy of child
separation at the u.s mexico border
that sessions and rosenstein were saying
separate kids from families no matter
how young they are
and it is absolutely disgusting to see
this
for me pat because we're very very used
to seeing
republicans kind of go along
with stuff because they calculate that
maybe the political implications are
good
or they're not damaging or it kind of um
makes up a bigger picture of a policy
platform that they have signed on to or
whatever the case may be
but even many of these republicans
aren't often going out of their way to
say
let's make this even more brutal and
immoral
that's exactly what rod rosenstein and
jeff sessions are accused of doing based
on this report they were going out of
their way to say
let's separate more people let's
separate even younger kids let's do it
all
yeah if it was steve bannon or stephen
miller pushing for this decision i
wouldn't be surprised by it at all
but i thought you know jeff sessions was
at least somewhat of a decent person
because he recused himself from the
russia investigation
uh in rod rosenstein in the same way he
appointed robert mueller
to look into trump's ties to russia so
we thought like maybe these people are
acting somewhat in good faith like they
don't agree with us on everything but
you know they're
in some areas they're patriots and
they're doing the right thing but this
just completely blows that stuff out of
the water because this is just
so disgusting the zero tolerance family
separation policy
and anyone who uh was in favor of this
they deserve to have their political
careers ended and indeed that seems to
be what had happened to
jeff sessions and rod rosenstein already
but for completely different reasons for
totally different reasons yeah and this
even includes i mean
understand that when we're talking about
when you say separate kids of any age
from their parents
you're talking about separating babies
that are breastfeeding from others that
that's actually what you are talking
about here it's it's a
you know completely incredible and then
you will hear from the right things like
listen if they didn't want their ability
to parent their kids
to be ruined they never should have come
to the united states in the first place
you can negotiate you can litigate the
legality
of coming to the united states the
morality of coming to the united states
that doesn't change that if you don't
want to see the united states like many
of the countries that these
right-wingers often refer to as [ __ ]
countries
then we have standards that we would
want to uphold for ourselves and so
regardless of what
the mom should have stayed in mexico if
she wanted to breastfeed her kid
that doesn't excuse our actions and
that's what's ignored when people say
that
that's exactly right you have to be on
team human first ahead of
team united states i think and if the
united states makes a terrible policy
that's immoral then you have to be able
to stand up and fight against that
and uh that's exactly what took place in
2018 when they had this zero tolerance
policy another thing that uh
right-wingers like to say is that obama
started this
right family separations and uh indeed
there were separations
under obama but it wasn't a matter of
zero tolerance like it became under the
trump administration
like sure there are going to be
instances where you have to separate
families i understand that like if
like a parent gets accused of murder or
you know is abusive to the child or
whatever you're gonna have to separate
that's just reality sure but the trump
administration made it so oh if you
cross the border and that'll that alone
that will make it so that we're going to
separate you from your child and that
was yeah absolutely disgusting
and they try to basically draw a moral
parallel and say obama and trump did the
same thing
trump just did it better and it was more
about law and order and it couldn't be a
framing that that's that's further from
the truth
one of the things we're looking at very
strongly for lack of a better term
is the senate balance coming uh up in
november
which will be put in place in january
and
right now as many of you know the senate
is 53 to 47 in favor of republicans
in order to take control of the senate
democrats need to either gain
four seats or three seats in the
presidency because in the case of a
50-50 tie
the president the vice president rather
becomes the tie-breaking vote in the
senate
and ultimately this could go either way
and because it's going to be possibly
very close it could come to come down to
only one election
and if it comes down to only one
election one state one race
it could come down to the race in north
carolina between the incumbent tom
tillis and the challenger cal cunningham
and if it does come down to that race it
could come down to some
romantic texts that challenger
cal cunningham the democrat has admitted
to sending to a woman who is not his
wife
now cal cunningham has admitted that he
did this cal cunningham said i've hurt
my family disappointed my friends and
i'm deeply sorry
the first step in repairing those
relationships is taking complete
responsibility which i do
i ask that my family's privacy be
respected in this personal
matter he's staying in the race he's
actually doing okay in the polls
um the texts pat listen i don't want to
moralize here about infidelity
needless to say many people cheat on
significant others
sometimes they're married sometimes
they're not there are different degrees
of this going on
all we know right now is that cal
cunningham sent they weren't even
particularly
aggressive texts they were just romantic
texts to a woman that is not his wife
i am not defending the actions but when
we're talking about such high stakes
it would be horrible to see the entire
senate balance come down to
romantic texts that cal cunningham sent
yeah that's definitely true
and of course his opponent tom tillis
has coronavirus right now so
who knows if those two things will
balance out like i don't know what
effect
this will all have on the polls yeah but
it's just silly how they're going to be
people in north carolina who clutch
their pearls over this uh
infidelity matter yet at the same time
they're gonna vote for donald trump
right who cheated on his wife at the
time when his son was being born
and doesn't even dispute that back like
trump doesn't even argue against the
stormy daniels allegations everyone just
accepted it to be true
and he was married at that time uh so
people are going to
but maybe you know trump was a democrat
at that time so they'll come up with
some sort of rationalization to vote for
trump and against cal cunningham on this
issue
i just think that because with all we're
dealing with right now
and you know the political polarization
people really paying attention to
politics more so than ever before
i don't think it's going to make that
much of a difference on the race i mean
maybe if this was 1998 it could have
cost cal cunningham the election but i
don't think there's going to be a
foreseeable effect
uh in this go around i i hope that
you're correct and as we start to look
at this you know when you
and you look at the different um races
that that we are looking at
if indeed joe biden is going to win as i
said democrats only need to recover
three seats
susan collins is not doing well in maine
cory gardner is not doing well in
colorado
martha mcsally is not doing well in
arizona that could be
it it's really important to understand
that could be all that you
need and then on top of that of course
there's the question in montana there's
the question
in north carolina i mean that this
really could be doable
yeah in south carolina too and iowa also
a toss-up
democrats are favored to get back to
majority but it's surely no
uh sure thing we will just have to see i
think if they do win back the senate
then they also unback the presidency i
don't see a scenario where
they win the senate but lost the
presidency no no no i mean
it's a good sign if biden wins he's
going to have control over the
legislative branch most likely and
he'll be able to do quite a lot with
that let's hope so because we don't want
i mean listen
okay obama got obama got obamacare done
in those first two years and that is
that is a major accomplishment obviously
we would have wanted obamacare to be
more but i think it is a fair criticism
that under the guise of bipartisanship
maybe or just not
blowing through the obstruction of
republicans obama left
things on the table that could have been
done during those first two years right
and we have to learn from that mistake
because
politics works like a pendulum right yes
things are looking good for democrats
now but it's certainly possible that
biden takes office and everyone's sick
of democrats and then they vote
democrats out in 2022
because this is just the back and forth
that we have in american politics so if
you can
get everything that you want done or at
least most of it in the first two years
then you set yourself up pretty well and
also if uh among those agenda items
include adding puerto rico and dc
estates
well then maybe you set yourself up so
that you're not in a position to lose
majorities in 2022
and that's what i would love that is uh
that is interesting and will will be an
uphill battle but we will not
put the cart before the horse we will
deal with what is before us today what
is before us today is many of you can
start early voting many of you can
already
do your absentee ballots as they have
started to be sent out and
all of you can join me tonight at 8 30
p.m eastern time
for the debate between kamala harris and
mike pence on youtube and twitch
i will see you then the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com